how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some awesome news today as a
major actor has joined the Marvel
Cinematic Universe coming up in the Loki
Disney Plus series it has been
officially reported by comicbook.com
that the Loki series has officially cast
Owen Wilson for a role in the upcoming
series this is major news and it
actually tells us a lot about the film
and we're gonna break it all down but
first real quick just want to thank
point club for sponsoring this video
point Club is a great way to earn some
extra cash and gift cards towards places
like Amazon Target Walmart Starbucks and
many other great places as well you can
earn cash and other rewards by watching
videos playing games taking research
surveys or shopping online to earn some
rewards I actually used to do this all
the time in college to make sure I
didn't run out of any money and I was
already on the internet watching videos
anyways so if you're interested click my
link in the description box down below
and you'll get a free $5 when you take
your first survey again Thank You Point
Club for sponsoring this video so the
report from comicbook.com says that
they've cast Owen Wilson as a major
character coming up in the low-key
Disney Plus series although that
character has not yet been revealed
however the fact that they cast Owen
Wilson just as a main character in the
show means two things one is that the
low-key series is probably going to be a
pretty funny series of course Owen
Wilson has done serious movies in the
past but he's mostly known for his
comedies some of his biggest movies are
of course wedding crashers Zoolander
meet the parents and Shanghai noon all
hilarious movies that Marvel probably
plans on Owen Wilson bringing that
comedy into the Loki series and another
thing is that Kevin Feige has very
clearly and obviously stated that the
characters that appear in Marvel's
Disney Plus shows will also appear in
the MCU films so the fact that Owen
Wilson was cast in the show means he
could most likely appear in other MCU
films since he's apparently been cast as
a major character and there are two
characters that Owen Wilson could
possibly be playing and one is dawn
Blake and the other is Erik Masterson
both of these characters are alternate
versions of Thor and it would make sense
that Loki would run into one of these
alternate versions of Thor since we know
he's going to be skipping around through
time and skipping around through the
multiverse we know that he's going to
encounter Kidd Loki we know that there's
going to be a female version of Loki so
it's very clear that he's all
ready going to run into different
alternate versions of himself it would
definitely make sense that he would see
alternate versions of Thor as well now
Donald the Blake was created by Odin to
be a host for his son Thor Odin's I de
that I was time for Thor to learn
humility and stripped him of his hammer
and sent him to earth the body that he
had was the body of Donald Blake and it
was a crippled body and if Owen Wilson
is going to be playing an alternate
version of Thor this is most likely the
version that he's going to be playing
because most of the versions of Thor are
pretty big muscular dudes
however Donald Blake isn't that muscular
and again he's kind of crippled however
there is definitely a chance that Owen
Wilson could bulk up for this role and
he could be playing Eric Masterson
otherwise known as Thunder strike now
Eric Masterson has kind of a weird story
in the comics Erika gets wounded in a
battle and Thor takes him to Odin and
begs him to spare his life and what Oh
Dan ends up doing is merging Eric and
Thor together as one they each have
their own separate personalities but
they share a body and since we're
dealing with the multiverse and multiple
realities in which some weird things
probably exist this is definitely an
option and Owen Wilson's long blond hair
kind of gives it away that he could be
playing an alternate version of Thor one
that is probably quite hilarious but let
me know what you think what do you think
about Owen Wilson being cast for the
Loki series coming to Disney Plus do you
think that he should play some alternate
version of Thor or do you think that he
should play a different character be
sure to let me know in the comments down
below of who you would like to see Owen
Wilson play don't forget to subscribe
when notifications turned on and like
this video so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 and picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll fluff